uh vaccines minister good to talk to you
uh today maggie through uh let's just
start with with guessing some of the
facts as how they've emerged over
christmas and new year how many britons
are currently in self-isolation
i'm not sure if that's actually a figure
but i think what is uh what's shown over
christmas is that a lot of people have
caught the disease that you know the
omri conveyor variant is very
transmissible but what is good news it
doesn't seem resulting in a severe
disease as some of the other variants
did so that is really good news and
obviously people were taking precautions
over christmas and i'd like to thank
them for that
you are
the minister for public health surely
you should know how many people are in
self-isolation
well not everybody declares that they're
self-isolating i think that's one
important thing that it's something that
they do uh because they've tested
positive or they've been in contact with
somebody who's set it positive they
don't have to uh report that in but i
think what has has been uh so clear over
recent weeks is that the the uh vaccine
is working and that's the best way to
stop the transmission and to stop
hospitalizations and for our life to get
back to normal
but in terms of of how we're going to
manage the nhs in coming days in terms
of how we're going to manage schools and
and even workplaces
how can the government do that if it
doesn't know how many people are
self-isolating when we know the latest
figures about positive tests for example
but you know over a million positive
tests that that means the people that
they know the people that they live with
will also have to self-isolate doesn't
it so we could be looking at four or
five million people potentially or even
more you just don't know
well i think the important thing is that
we are looking at the data all the time
with regards to hospitalizations as you
say people who have actually tested
positive and also a number of people in
the uh the high dependency units as well
i think at the moment if you look at
people have been hospitalized then they
are going in with less severe conditions
than before and the numbers that are in
hospital beds is about half what it was
a year ago and that just shows the power
of the vaccine and my message today is
if you haven't come forward through your
booster yet come forward if you haven't
had your first dose of vaccine or
delayed your second dose that there's
always chance to come forward to get
those
life-saving vaccines it's never too late
and that offer is always open well we'll
come on to nhs in a moment but it on the
subject of vaccines there were around
two million booster appointments that
have yet been taken we know that a lot
of booster centers were even on
christmas day um
is this that people are not bothering to
get their booster or have they got a
booked appointment
and they they've then gone to a walk-in
center and got it separately why do you
think there are so many appointments
that are are being missed for boosters
i'm not sure about it's being missed but
we did open up the national booking
service so people could come along and
get a vaccine when they went when they
booked the vaccine or the walking
centers as well and they were hugely
hugely popular before christmas and you
know so many people took up that offer
over 34 million there are two million
vaccine appointments available this week
um you know
you're desperate physical to get
vaccines why why are all these
appointments available
well it's quite right that we have those
opportunities there for people to come
forward to get their booster be wrong of
us if we should shut down the national
booking service and just expected people
to go into walk-ins it's quite right
that offer is there for people to book
their vaccine where it's their boosted
dose or as i said their first dose or
second dose that offer is always open
and it's quite right that across the
country people can make their
their appointment and come forward for
their vaccine
but in terms of numbers only a hundred
thousand were were boosted yesterday so
the numbers have really declined haven't
they
i think we you know we've just been
through two weekends of bank holiday and
i think that's you know quite clear that
numbers will change as we move forward
and what was really incredible is the
number of people coming forward on
christmas day and even on the bank
holidays we had more people coming
forward on the bank holidays than other
bank holidays in the past so people have
really taken the vaccine program to
heart and it's probably the most
successful vaccine program that the nhs
has ever run and probably one of the
most successful across the whole world
as well and i want to thank everybody
for playing their part whether it's the
nhs the thousands if millions of
volunteers that have really helped made
a difference and people coming forward
to get that that life-saving vaccine in
such a timely way
nevertheless we're seeing critical
incidents at a number of hospitals um
how how many exactly uh how many we
think about half a dozen nhs trusts have
had critical incidents because of staff
shortages how many exactly do you know
well i think the critical incidents are
announced and then there can be very
short term ones
and it's saying to the other trusts
around you can we have some extra help
can we have the mutual aid sometimes
it's just a matter of hours that the
critical instance in place for other
times it's longer but it's actually
reaching out to the the wider nhs to say
yeah we have got a problem in this
particular area and it is sometimes
quite geographical as well and for
different reasons it could be staff
shortages it could be other reasons so
it's quite wrong do you know how many
tests you know how many were out this
morning for example i know as you say it
is fast moving but
you know what are the latest figures
from this morning
well it is fast moving that's why it'd
be wrong with me to actually
say a number because you know quite
shortly there could be another one or
another trust could actually say no
we're back on track now and we're okay
and it's a mechanism that's been put in
place in the past and yeah i'm sure is
it is it sorry but is it wrong wrong for
you to say i mean we wouldn't want you
to mislead but you know it strikes me
that perhaps you just don't know
to be to be honest i haven't had an
update this morning as we know the uh
lincolnshire hospital trust declared one
yesterday and those have declared them
in the past and i think as i've said it
can be very short-lived and
and it can be longer as well but it's
for different reasons sometimes it's
staff shortages sometimes it's bed
capacity it's complete mixture and it's
quite right you're the minister of
vaccines
you're the minister for vaccines and
public health the government has put you
up today to talk to us about
covert to talk about the pressure on the
nhs and to reflect on the last 12 months
of the astrazeneca vaccine but
surely in that case you should know how
many nhs trusts are in critical measures
at the moment and indeed how many people
in the uk are self-isolated they seem to
be
really key bits of data that the public
want to know they want to know how many
people are self-isolating they want to
know if their local hospital trust is in
a critical condition or not does the
government have a handle on this
it definitely does and obviously there's
meetings on a very very well on a daily
basis with the key people in within nhs
england and they've been updated later
on on that situation but as i've said
that you know the best thing to do to
help to protect the nhs and to make sure
that other major uh uh infrastructure
can continue is people to come forward
for their vaccines as you say it's
actually just a year today since the uh
brian pinker had that first oxford
astrocennic
vaccine out of clinical trials and
that's a real good milestone and it's an
amazing achievement for british research
and innovation that since then over 50
million of those doses of the
astrozenica vaccine has been put into
arms in the uk
and 2.5 billion doses across the world
have been administered of that
particular vaccine and it's testament to
the work that's gone on within the uk
absolutely and nobody wants to take away
from that but but equally all we also
have to to look at the current
situations we have it now not the
situation over the last 12 months and
the royal college of nursing have called
on saudi jabba to work with counterparts
across government for a more cautious
approach in england um the the rcns also
said it's concerned about the fact that
there are different regulations in
different parts
of the uk nations we're hearing about
pressure on maternity departments we
know that some hospitals in the north
are now not allowing visitors again
it does seem that the messaging that's
coming from the health service is that
the government needs to be doing more is
the government listening is the
government prepared to bring in more
restrictions
look as the prime minister said
yesterday that we have got plan b which
is people working from home uh the the
kovid pass
face coverings and obviously the vaccine
program which is so so important and
these are all important but if they're
not working if we have six trusts in
critical measures then it suggests that
the plan b possibly isn't as effective
as it might be and that do we need to be
looking at planning
the plan b is working
as you can see from the number of
hospitalizations it's far far fewer than
this time
last year and that's so important as
well that you know the vaccines are
working the measures for people to work
from home are working and we you know
people have been really really compliant
it's really good news that people want
to do their uh part to make sure that we
get this virus under control and yes the
prime minister said that you know plan b
is working there'll be a cabinet meeting
today and i i don't see any reason why
we need to change it's important that we
do follow the data we've done that all
along and we'll continue to do that and
you know people are playing their part
and i want to thank them for that
you talking about the vaccines and how
important they are um
why are we then selling off at a uk
vaccine development center near oxford
the the vaccine manufacturing and
innovation center i mean that doesn't
seem like a
great confidence boost does it that if
we are selling off these facilities as
soon as they appear successful
well i wouldn't want to comment on the
commercial decision but i think what is
important that we've got um good supply
of vaccines you know we've we've got the
the fires in the modern astrazeneca and
others coming online as well and it's
important that people do come forward uh
for those first vaccines and the second
one as well
that offer is always open and i think
what was really encouraging as well as
the booster program uh was turbocharged
more people came forward for their first
dose as well i think they've seen just
how important it is they've seen other
people get the vaccine and they've also
sadly heard the people say that they've
been seriously ill because they haven't
well they haven't had the vaccine and to
put that message out that vaccines are
important that do as save people from
getting serious disease and they do save
lives
yeah despite that we still have six
trusts and critical incidents um maggie
through parliamentary under secretary of
state for vaccines and public health
thank you very much